et
[Musique]
on n'arrive pas du tout plu du tout les
coûts de la vie sont extrêmement hr la
paix caroline maurice simard comme bien
des mères au québec
fait face au casse-tête de l'inflation
montre comment les enfants ont jamais
manqué de rien sata mais je suis
vraiment roche ça me fait beaucoup par
elle et son conjoint est honteux revenus
qui totalise environ 40000 dollars ils
n'arrivent plus dans leur budget
caroline habite sept-îles où les vies
coûtait déjà plus cher selon une étude
de l'iris le revenu nécessaire ici pour
couvrir les dépenses essentielles et un
minimum d'un prévue est de 72 1300 $
pour une famille de 4
soit 7000 $ de plus que la moyenne des
principales villes du québec en région
éloignée on le voit il ya des prix qui
ont pu élever un peu partout parce que
oui les coûts du transport notamment et
donc en période d'inflation mais ça
affecte aussi les autres prix comme ceux
des aliments
ça me coûte 200 $ de plus par mots pour
être capable
elle va donc au comptoir alimentaire de
la ville pour avoir de l'aide elle ya
droit huit fois par année et en ressort
avec une épicerie complète pour sa
famille r comme dauphin 1 1 c'est moral
en même temps parce que c'est des gens
très ouverts effectué comme quand tu
arrives pis ça va porter ils vont te
poser la question je les adore pour
mettre les voiles d'avant dakar
on devrait dépasser notre maximum cette
année on s'attend
à dépasser les 1600 dépannage pour
l'année sais-tu des paniers comme tu
disais ce matin depuis juillet le
comptoir alimentaire de sept-îles a
doublé le nombre de sacs d'épicerie
qu'il distribue ça fait des choses que
forget en eau des familles qu'on n'a
jamais eue on a de nouvelles clientèles
qu'on n'a jamais connu donc les besoins
des familles est vraiment différent par
rapport à l'an passé où les années
précédant cet endroit là derrière moi ça
c'est le car la ville présentement un
coeur qui bat grâce à la générosité de
la population
comme celle de cet homme venu apporter
de la nourriture
parce qu'il faut le dire une partie de
la population de sept-îles travail à
l'aluminerie ou à la mine et gagnent
plus de 125 1000 $ par n la dernière
minute à des kangourous en un mot c'est
loin d'être le cas pour johan et bernard
comme bien des années l'inflation leur
fait mal
j'ai absolument à rien monsieur moi
alors on vit avec la pension de
vieillesse que mon mari au sa régie des
rentes puis elle doit au supplément de
revenu garanti à voir sur quoi ce qui
arrive sur vous là où avec la voix de
cash au delà le chercheur aujourd'hui tu
vas trop tu détail peuple ils vont venir
à spéciale
ils n'ont pas le choix de tout calculer
comme cette visite à québec qu'il
s'apprête à faire chez la fille de
bernard on l'avait décidé qu'on allait
pas parce qu'on payait au sud devient
salée jovial et c'était pas si grave et
ça c'est mon pire je m'écroule contrôle
à 100 mais tu te pour boire des barbeaux
les tubules pour deux ans
les résidents de cette île doivent
d'ailleurs payé au moins 6000 $ de plus
que ceux des grandes villes du québec
pour se déplacer selon l'étude de l'iris
et à sept-îles le transport en commun
est très limité il faut absolument avoir
une voiture pour assurer ses
déplacements voire de voitures quand on
est une famille avec deux jeunes enfants
et donc ça fait en sorte que le coût de
la vie y est plus élevé
caroline finissait course à pied son
conjoint parti travailler avec leur
première voiture
leur deuxième est brisé elles n'ont pas
les moyens de la faire réparer
l'épicerie chez arthur où elle s'arrête
est une institution à sept-îles c'est ce
qu'on est obligé d'augmenter les
salaires pourquoi être jeu de courir
après nos employés commence notre
information 17 ça va aller à
22h24 selon l'expérience
sur la côte nord la forte pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre alimente la spirale
inflationniste
le loyer à monte et descend ça monte
parce qu'on est obligé de mettre la
montée des services de livraison aussi
un état trop de l'orne a monté sa
cathédrale fait qu'en réalité c'est le
client qui finit par payer parce que moi
j'ai pris mon jugement mépris en pleine
campagne électorale les fassions de la
vie ses électeurs lance donc un message
au futur gouvernement beauté et rentes
si j'avais ça c'est qu'un pièce mettant
plus de parme au mess précieuse et très
bien qu'on sait capable de mettre des
loyers au bourg
dans une ville que oui on est loin de
tout retard transport saut comme des
milliers de québécois il demande un peu
d'air pour alléger leur quotidien
moi ça me fait comme un expert panier
par entend pas je fais beaucoup
angoissent pis d'accéder au fait que
c'est tellement cher